يستمر الرئيس ترامب
في الادعاء دون أساس في الواقع أن
الانتخابات القادمة لن تكون صادقة.
كاتب العمود في نيويورك تايمز توم فريمان لديه
عقود من الخبرة في تغطية القادة في
جميع أنحاء العالم الذين
يحاولون البقاء في السلطة ، وهو أيضًا
مؤلف الكتاب الأكثر مبيعًا
والمزدحم لماذا  نحن بحاجة لثورة
خضراء وكيف يمكن أن تجدد أمريكا
هو ينضم إلي الآن كما تعلمون توم أننا لعبنا
بيان الرئيس ريغان أه
عندما ألقى خطاب تنصيبه
الأول وأول ما تناوله هو
الطبيعة الشائعة
للانتقال السلمي للسلطة والثناء.  جيمي
كارتر
لأنه جعل الأمر سهلاً لتسهيل
الأمر ، فهو أمر شائع في هذا البلد في
الخارج
حيث يرتدي الرؤساء
زيًا عسكريًا مزيفًا واه عندما
يديرون عائلاتهم
فروعًا
حكومية أخرى أه
هم لا يفعلون ذلك.  لقد كان هناك انتقال سلمي
للسلطة ،
لقد فوجئت بأن الرئيس
قال هذا ، أعني
أنك تعرف أن الكثير من الناس يقولون ر
نعم ، إنه أمر مذهل ولكن ليس
مفاجئًا ، لقد
وجدت الأمر مذهلًا
ومدهشًا.
الحرب الأهلية الثانية المحتملة في
تاريخها ، أنت تعتقد حقًا أن
ما حدث في
الأيام القليلة الماضية
هو حريق إنذار ستة أعتقد
أنه defcon5 أخبرنا رئيس الولايات المتحدة
إما أنني فزت في الانتخابات
أو ألغيت شرعية الانتخابات
هذه هي اختياراتك يا رفاق
وهو يحاول بشكل أساسي كسر
إرادة
الناس لجعل الناس يقولون حقًا ما
الذي يريده سيئًا للغاية ، فقط
أعطيه إياه ،
وأعتقد أن هذه بالتأكيد هي
أكثر اللحظات المخيفة
في حياتي  أم أنه مخيف بسببه
إنه مخيف لأنه مدعوم من
شبكة مملوكة للدولة
وهو مرعب لأن
الحزب الجمهوري أصبح في الأساس
سياسيًا.  بيت الدعارة
الذي يؤجر نفسه بالليل
من سينشط قاعدته
أه سواء كانت سارة بالين أو حفلة الشاي
والآن ترامب أم
هذا حزب دخل
مؤتمره بدون منصة
ولا منصة قال أساسًا
ما يريده ترامب
أه وثانيًا إذا لم تخافوا
الآن إذا لم
تخافوا لما يمكن أن يحدث فليس
لدينا انتخابات متنازع
عليها أه نحن سنجري انتخابات متنازع عليها
أه يكاد يكون مؤكدًا ما لم
يفوز ترامب
أه في هذه الحالة اممم  أرتجف من التفكير في
شكل أربع سنوات أخرى من هذا